scott disick
might have been spotted hanging out with
amelia hamlin
you know the 19 year old daughter of
lisa rinna and harry hamlin
but a source tells e.t it's not serious
let's just focus on what's real and
what's happening the two sparked romance
rumors after they were seen together
celebrating halloween and again out in
montecito california but our source says
scott is
not looking for a relationship adding
that they have mutual friends
quote they've hung out and gone on a
couple dates but they're not a couple
according to our source the woman
scott's been spending the most time with
is his ex and mama to his three kids
kourtney kardashian
quote scott and courtney are together
all the time for the sake of the kids
but also because they're such good
friends and get along
so well i think you just gotta figure
out really what's important to you at
the end of the day
abcdefg i have to go
what the heck is abcdefg mean so
could this mean they're getting back
together our source says
don't hold your breath they have a good
thing going and it works perfectly for
their family
according to the source scott's main
priority is taking care of himself
and being there for his family which
we'll see on the season 19 finale of
keeping up with the kardashians
i go to therapy every week but i never
have like any breakthroughs and i never
feel happy you know what i mean like i
just didn't grieve my parents correctly
or give it enough time
i just want to be the best person i can
be for my family
earlier this year scott whose parents
died three months apart from each other
in 2013 and 2014
entered a rehab facility to work on some
of his past
traumas at the end of the day i mean you
just want to be happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable on the season 19 finale of
the hit reality show
fans will see the moment scott told
court he was struggling while
quarantining amid the coronavirus
pandemic
and needed to go get help
[Music]
like i just can't handle having nothing
really to do
and the truth was i started feeling more
and more anxious more and more depressed
like i was gonna do something bad if i
didn't figure something out or take
myself
out of this position and court she was
totally on
and stuff and you're board with
everything i would go for like
at least a month yeah i mean i'm good
i'm good with the kids i am caught a
little off guard you know because for
the first time
scott isn't being asked to go away he
isn't
having an issue with alcohol or drugs
and it's like his idea
so i think it feels really different
this time i think it's really like
bringing up like important work that we
all have to do i think we've been
through so much in so many things and to
hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
[Music]
me